a 42 here as you all know that the
strange species of human called
vegetarians and there's an even more
peculiar species called vegans and for a
long time both groups have grudgingly
been asking the same question do plants
have feelings do they have a motion by
cause do they feel pain if the answer
turns out to be yes then those
aforementioned groups of people are
really school and that may very well be
the case because research conducted by
forest scientists over a thirty-year
period reveals that trees have some
amazing social skills trees can actually
talk to each other and this isn't just
basic communication either they have an
impressively large vocabulary when you
walk through the forest there are
hundreds of conversations happening
right below your feet but you won't hear
a word because trees don't communicate
via speech but through electrical
impulses just like the human nervous
system underneath the soil a tree's
roots spread out horizontally as far
wide after tree is tall if not more as
they grow sideways they also intertwine
and connect with the roots of all the
other trees that surround it not only
can a tree stand electrical signals to
its direct neighbors but by relaying
messages from tree to tree they can talk
to each other even if they are many
trees apart this interconnected network
of roots is referred to as the wood wide
web in this sense a forest really is one
singular living organism even the fungi
join in connecting themselves into the
root base social network communicating
with the trees so what caused trees
possibly be same to each other
well mostly at meat and food mate when
trees get low on certain elements which
they used to grow such as carbon
phosphorus and sulfur they send a
request out into the wood wide web the
closest tree that house some of these
elements spare will send the carbon for
example to the tree that cell
the requests and how do they send these
nutrients well through the routes of
course not only do these magnificent
biological super highways act as a
communication network but they also
carry physical elements all around the
forest sharing the resources out equal
them tree even look out for one another
if they notice a particular tree isn't
getting enough sunlight they will slowly
reconfigure their branches to let extra
light through and puff on more vitamins
and nutrients to that tree oldham six
trees also get extra love and care from
their neighbors they may even choose to
disconnect their roots from certain
trees if they're not welcome in the
community such as dead rotten trees have
you ever noticed how trees seem to copy
each other
changing appearance and dropping their
leaves around the same time it's as if
they're all perfectly synchronized well
that's because they are trees also
possess the ability to count they
collectively count the passing days and
keep track of how many warm days there
are throughout the summer and spring
each year they then share this knowledge
throughout the forest and use it to open
their book at the optimum time they do
the same thing to the cold days during
the winter so they all know exactly when
to start shedding Nelly's in preparation
for the cold weather now don't worry as
far as we know it's very unlikely that
trees and any other plants for that
matter can feel pain they lack the
required nerves required to experience
the sensation but they certainly do have
personality there are good trees that
put all their efforts into helping
governor organisms and bad trees that
steal more nutrients than they really
should be doing it's even been theorized
that trees can make decisions and have
memories and they even have Wars species
such as beech and oak are very family
orientated and ferociously protect their
own and yes
incredibly trees do know which trees are
their own children a parent trees will
pump sugar
solutions through their routes to their
children to support their growth this
enables the baby trees to grow up and
live a longer life family groups will
purposely deprive other species growing
nearby to try and push them out of that
forest as practically the ghetto out
there a massive thank you to audible who
teamed up with me on this video they are
offering everyone watching this video
the chance to try audible free for 30
days they have an unrivaled selection of
audio books original shows news comedy
and more I always put an audiobook on
when traveling it's such an interesting
way to pass the time
audible are offering a free audiobook
with your 30 day free trial simply go to
audible.com forward slash 40 sign up for
your free trial download your first
title and start listening in preparation
for this video I've been listening to
the hidden life of trees by Forester
Peter wall oven it's all about how trees
communicate with each other and form
their own social network now you may not
think a book about trees could be
particularly interesting but I promise
you this one is truly fascinating trees
have so many incredible secrets and
they're all inside this audio book so go
to audible.com forward slash 40 and
start listening to it today you won't
regret it
thanks for watching